I'll turn into a rant hey what's up
MKBHD here okay you know it's gotten uh
a little Annoying lately overusing the
word confirmed so I was on Twitter
yesterday maybe I spent too much time on
Twitter I think we all kind of do to
some extent but I saw iPhone 13 trending
for almost no reason but you kind of see
this every once in a while like the
iPhone will just Trend because people
see the name of the new one and they
think it just came out because it's
trending on Twitter but it's trending
for no reason so then this Forbes
article pops up right in the middle of
it Apple's massive iPhone 13 upgrades
suddenly confirmed do you remember when
the official dictionary definition of
literally was adjusted to include
figurative use because people misused it
so many times it just became part of how
it's used I feel like that's what's
happening with the word confirmed here
nothing about the iPhone 13 is confirmed
nothing is confirmed until Apple goes on
stage in September like they always do
and announces and shows what the new
iPhone 13 is until then nothing is
actually confirmed so this article if
you made the mistake of going through
and actually clicking on it like I did
it's just it's just cherry picking a
two-week-old everything Apple pro video
and everything Apple Pro great guy
Philip I've met him love the videos
respect what he does he does regular
reporting and renders slash mock-ups to
like help visualize leaks and rumors
about upcoming iPhones just fun video
stuff he even calls it leaks in the
video's title and he collaborates on
this particular video with Max Weinbach
who also presents some new Rumors in the
form of leaks some of which may be true
Others May turn out not to be true but
then Forbes or at least this one writer
turning around and calling it confirmed
is pretty much useless that's not
actually What's Happening Here If you
happen to trust Forbes for your your
regular source of tech reporting or
information I wouldn't think that this
builds any confidence in that so you
know what I'll link Phillips video down
below if you actually want to catch up
on the latest leaks and rumors about the
new iPhone which include like a maybe
smaller Notch and a refined matte black
texture all that fun stuff shout out to
him
anyway speaking of Twitter I figured I'd
do a q a because I haven't done one in a
little bit and I do enjoy these a lot in
the quiet time of year where not a lot
of tech is coming out asked you on
Twitter what you wanted to know and
these are your best questions favorite
Daft Punk album and song oh man this is
a tough one I I hope I'm not the one
breaking the news to you by now but in
case you didn't know after 28 years of
uh kind of Epic career Daft Punk is no
more they put out a video it's over
there will be no no more Daft Punk which
is actually pretty sad but they had
incredible impact on music and in
electronics and Tech in the music world
I I honestly feel like Ram
is
it's the best produced albums I have
different answers for different stuff
they've made I think recency bias I have
to say random access memories is like
it's one of my favorite albums ever and
super well produced but I think
Discovery is their best album and my
personal favorite Daft Punk song changes
all the time I think right now I would
say it's actually too long
might not be a common answer but I love
that song do you have any Tech that you
weren't excited about at first but now
has become something that you use pretty
frequently oh interesting question
Braden the thing that comes to mind for
me is a mechanical keyboard I didn't use
a mechanical keyboard for years I had
always edited and was really fast on
Chiclet style keys with literally the
one that came with my MacBook uh and
this this whole mechanical keyboard
thing really grew on me I've been using
one called the ketron ketron K2 and then
the K3 came out but I stuck with the K2
and my custom keys and there's actually
a really great video recently I'll link
below a YouTuber who rebuilt the K2 with
like a sweet red and black theme and
some new quieter switches and he's going
to send it to me so if it gets here
maybe it'll show up in a video but that
I thought was pretty sweet
okay Renee Ritchie's got a question if
you could Jurassic Park up any extinct
phone Droid or Palm Pre or Lumia or
anything and go fully on fully modern
updated version what would it be and why
and actually I feel like I immediately
know I'm gonna go HTC One M8 Google Play
edition that phone kicked if I could get
a fully updated version of that phone
going it didn't have the best camera
which was like it's its biggest downside
but the build quality all metal unibody
front-facing speakers get that on the
newest version of Android I would that I
would use that phone today that would be
pretty sweet I think even a matte black
version existed this is probably
trolling well Apple's car support
Android auto I think if there's anything
if Apple even ever makes a car we know
nothing about it but I think there's one
thing I can probably say which is
probably won't support Android auto you
know it's funny I saw a Hyundai the
other day it's one of the new I think
it's a Sonata or something like that
and I've talked about this before on the
waveform podcast but when I think of
Apple car it's so hard for me to imagine
anything other than like a perfect white
sphere that like rolls down the street
like I don't know what an Apple car
looks like but I saw that Hyundai and
there's all these rumors about Hyundai
working with apple and it's got these
lines for the headlights that go all the
way up and like merge with the Chrome so
you don't know where the drl's end and
the Chrome begins from afar and I looked
at that and I said I could see an Apple
logo on that
I could see that
doesn't seem that crazy to me but this
is a very far off into the future type
stuff can you speak Spanish
you know hablo mucho espanol pero yo
comprehendo
hablo all right there's a comment here a
question about do you think electric car
manufacturers could get rid of the
charging port like apple did with their
phones
in the near future and he says in the
near future not anytime in the near
future and this has always been such a
weird thing about Apple using the
environmental excuse as to why they're
getting rid of chargers well the fact of
the matter is wireless charging since
you're replacing ports with wireless
charging wireless charging is very
inefficient and therefore directly
impacting against that environmental
gain when you use way more power to
charge the same phone inefficiently so
when you you scale that up to an
electric car that's very inefficient for
a very large battery there's no way
wireless charging and anytime in the
near future is going to be a great idea
but that being said I love where your
head's at maybe someday wireless
charging can get so direct and so good
that all you have to do is drive over
like a wireless charging pad in your
garage and as long as you're somewhere
near the right place it'll charge
overnight that would be pretty sweet
but that's nowhere near the near future
all right so of all the tech you get to
see Slash use what was the last thing
that you saw which made you think wow
this is the future
huh
I like that question I'm gonna ask it to
everyone here in the studio my answer
I think I'm just gonna say electric cars
in general like not a lot of stuff
really blows my mind because I get to
see the steps of things as they happen
but I think the first time I got to
drive an electric car and really
experience it I was like oh yeah this
will be how all cars are in the future
it might not be the last one but the
biggest piece or like the biggest this
is the future moments probably VR
there's just that aspect of taking off
the goggles and realizing you're in a
room and not on a mountain or not waving
a lightsaber and I feel like
that was just the moment where I felt
like I left my body because of
Technology I'm gonna go with Boston
Dynamics spot I think is the dog's name
um just because it looks like
something out of a sci-fi movie and it
has better balance than I do like if you
try pushing me over I will fall
and that thing did not
I'm gonna have to go with all of
computational Imaging and video but
particularly Adobe announced content to
wear fill in video for After Effects
where you can just remove whole people
or things from the video and the fact
that they democratize that for everyone
kind of freaked me out a little bit
because now we don't really know what's
real
[Music]
Arun says if you could take the hardware
from one phone and the software from
another which combo would you have so I
think it's pretty easy I'd take a Galaxy
s20 one Ultra and I'd put like stock
Android I'd do a Google Play edition
Google Play edition that's that's the
two things I'd combine I did a little
more of a detailed tweet which I ran out
of characters but about like the
Frankenstein phone I would make from a
bunch of pieces but I run if I could
only pick two it's this Hardware which
is pretty sweet
and like a Nexus what objectively
terrible product do you regularly use
either because of necessity or because
you love them despite their flaws
there's not a lot of like objectively
terrible Tech that you end up having to
keep around
but you know what is objectively
terrible
printers like that's the one piece of
tech we all have that reminds us that
we're not living in the future we know
we don't have flying cars but you know
there's a lot of futuristic stuff around
printers that have just been bad
since the beginning I wonder what would
happen if like Google or Apple or
someone just decided to make a good
printer like can that could that really
be done there's a lot of product
categories out there that I wish they'd
get into but what if Apple just made a
good printer it's got a screen that you
can actually type on it doesn't get jams
all the time it's probably 700 bucks but
what would that look like that's it's
another weird one is there any retro
Tech episode coming anytime soon yes I'm
not gonna spoil exactly what's going
down but it's going to be a fun one
we've finished shooting season two and
it's a little different from season one
and there's a lot of good stuff that I
can't wait to share it's in the
production editing phase and it is
coming soon keep an eye out for that oh
look did you put a reservation for the
Tesla Model S plaid yet I don't know if
this person's joking or if they saw my
tweet
I can all explain I'll explain later
there's more to it than you think
just wait and see I'll explain uh what's
one of those little things that very few
people talk about that's still very cool
I just can I just give a shout out to
NASA this is an unofficial NASA shirt
but can we give a shout out to NASA
there's a Rover
that just last week landed on Mars
and since landing on Mars which is
already amazing it has sent back tens of
thousands of photos
4K videos of the landing and of the
Martian surface that is unreal for some
reason to me that the video of it
Landing with a parachute pops out and
it's going like 900 meters per second or
something crazy but it pops out and then
you see the rocket dangle the robot down
landed on Mars and then fly away all of
that has already been sent back to Earth
tens of millions of miles in 4k I don't
know this this is that that is future
type stuff I'm excited for what the
perseverance Mission can end up
uncovering they've landed it right where
they wanted it to we're looking for
signs of Life on another planet this is
a great this is an exciting time to be
alive shout out to NASA and then we got
the classic
single NBA question who will be in the
NBA finals this year
so
I think it's got to be the Nets is if
they're this is all my NBA predictions
will be if healthy right so if the
entire NBA every team is fully healthy
I gotta see the Nets coming out of the
East which is exciting because they're
in their backyard out of the West it's a
little more interesting if healthy which
ad is very important
I see the Lakers being the team to beat
but the Jazz look so good
I had Mike Conley on my fantasy team I
feel like the Jazz are like they kind of
look like the Hawks that one year where
they had like a bunch of All-Stars and
won a ton of games and then sort of
flamed out in playoffs we'll see how
they how they do but they're really
exciting team to watch I also have Rudy
gobert on my fantasy team shout out to
the Jazz but yeah I feel like it's the
Nets and the Lakers oh that's a good
update so is the form to apply to work
here still open and if so for how much
longer it is still open but as you can
tell we have been making moves and the
team has start to build so I will adjust
that form I'll adjust the form for what
things are still being added and I'll
try to share updates on Twitter if
you're not already following on Twitter
if you haven't guessed by now I use it a
lot for all kinds of stuff so follow
over there okay can I be in the intro or
outro of this video
yeah yeah actually you can you can be in
the outro
thanks for watching
peace